a Zelda game without bosses is like a
burger with only meat in it and don't
get me wrong down here in Texas we're
big on meat but where's the melty cheese
the succulent bacon the freshly chopped
jalapeno peppers Zelda bosses are what
give the Zelda games their unique
flavors and any fan of the franchise can
relate to that with my recent two-part
tiers of the Kingdom boss lore video
officially wrapping up all the 3D Zelda
bosses to date it's finally time to
tackle the ogs the 2D Zelda games and
what better a game to start with than
the gaming Titan the early '90s that is
a link to the past so sit back relax
prepare to be explained upon and oh yeah
spoiler alert obviously now I will say
most of the bosses of A Link to the Past
are fairly easily understood as either
naturally monstrous creatures that were
essentially placed in dungeons as bosses
in order to guard important artifacts or
monsters that were created by Ganon in
order to guard the maidens he kidnapped
so let's cover all of those first
starting with the bosses of the Dark
World which were most likely either
created by Ganon directly or just found
and placed there after being converted
into monstrous Dark World forms which
we'll get to a bit later the
dinosaur-like helmasaur king is the boss
of the first dungeon link clears in the
Dark World the Palace of Darkness it's
quite obviously just the biggest variant
of the much smaller and much more
numerous helmasaur monsters that can be
found inhabiting several dungeons of the
Dark World implying they were planted
there by Ganon all of which wear helmets
in order to guard their heads leaving
their backsides vulnerable to attack
however in the case of the giant helmet
King his backside looks to be pretty
safe from attacks his tail has also
grown quite long and he uses it in
attacks to lash out at link like a
scorpion though it just physically
bashes enemies and doesn't serve to
actually inject Venom once link has
destroyed its helmet its vulnerable head
is exposed with a gemstone that must be
attacked in order to destroy it
completely interestingly the boss's name
in Japanese is G kuroku the same name as
the Helmer Rock King from Wind Waker
which aside from being you know a giant
bipedal bird instead of of a giant
quadrupedal dinosaur shares the exact
same similarities with wearing a helmet
for armor that must be destroyed by link
before revealing its much more
vulnerable bare head underneath this is
perhaps indicative of the helmaroc king
and subsequently the cararo being the
evolved version of the helmasaur king
and the helmasaur however cararo don't
wear helmets like the helmasaur do but I
digress the next Monster would be Argus
with two RS Argus is the boss of the
swamp Palace also located within the
Dark World and attacks using its
children well that's theoretical but
listen it surrounds itself with little
enemies called our guy that in reality
are little polyps with Argus being a
oneeyed jellyfish monster and with
polyps being an early stage of
development in the life cycle of a
jellyfish and with the name AR guy being
extremely similar to Argus I'm pretty
sure they're actually just little
jellyfish babies that must have come
from the only big jellyfish in the room
anyway Argus and its children attack
link with physical moves as in they
physically attempt to run into link to
harm him after all the kiddos are taken
care of Argus flies around and slams
down on the water covered floor darting
around the room in an attempt to knock
link around there are no other copies of
this enemy species located anywhere else
within the game meaning this monster
either found its way to the boss room
itself of the swamp Palace or it was
placed there by someone interestingly
this boss also shares its Japanese name
which is wat with wart a very similar
giant eyeball boss from Major's mask
that also covers itself with smaller
enemies in this case just blobs that
damage link on impact with both bosses
appearing in water temples it could be
that these species of monsters also
share an evolutionary connection the
third boss in the dark world would be
mothula which resides within the Skull
Woods and just like its name suggests is
a giant moth monster truth be told there
isn't much more to its existence than
this simple fact though it is
interesting to note that mothula has
also appeared in several other Zelda
games both 2D and 3D Like the Wind Waker
where it appears as simply a spe species
of monstrous moths whose development can
be witnessed firsthand as you can even
see the spiky little baby versions
called mors spawn directly from bigger
mulas even though it's non- Canon it's
also interesting to note that in the El
Link to the Past manga mothula was
originally a woman that hailed from the
light world who traveled to the Dark
World in an attempt to become the most
beautiful woman alive but of course this
backfired and upon entering the Dark
World underwent a transformation into a
big moth which is the next best thing of
course the next monster is Vitus the
boss of the misery Meer dungeon within
the Dark World Vitus is yet another
giant eyeball monster surrounded by
little versions of itself in this case
just smaller eyeballs that it sends out
from its pool of gelatinous ooze that it
sits in which probably tastes great it
also shoots lightning at link before
deciding to try to crush him directly
once again the most interesting thing
about this boss is its Japanese name
which is pronounced guoga which sounds
very similar to The Dig dogger enemy
from the original zeld which is also a
giant eyeball it was likely named Vitus
in the English version of A Link to the
Past after Vitus humor which is the
clear gel that makes up the majority of
an eyeball yeah apparently eyeball
enemies and The Legend of Zelda go hand
in hand and speaking of eyeballs we're
still not done yet because the last
eyeball boss of the game is known as
cold stair and is the boss of the Ice
Palace in the Dark World this eyeball
surrounds itself in a cloud which is
then encased in ice from which it rains
ice down upon Link in an attempt to kill
him with ice which sounds remarkably
similar to another boss in the franchise
once its ice Shield is broken off it
splits itself into three eyeball clouds
that each must be destroyed it never
appears anywhere else in the cannon
franchise so there's really not much
more to be said about cold stair but
another fun fact about the beasty would
be that in the manga its name is Cold
Stone and also it can talk apparently
the more you know the next boss monster
of the Dark World would be trinex the
boss of Turtle Rock ironically enough
trinex is actually a giant turtle
monster monster with its main head
poking out from underneath its rock-like
shell and two additional serpent-like
heads that possess the elements of Fire
and Ice jutting out from the left and
right sides of the shell respectively
once the elemental heads are defeated
the shell combusts and disintegrates
leaving trinex shelless and legless
strangely it can still slide around the
place like a serpent though until being
killed by link of course its Japanese
name is deur Roku which is of course
very similar to J kuroku the helmasaur
king and implies a connection between
the two both are Ian quadrupedal and
protect themselves using outer shells of
some kind it also appears to have a
similarity to the classic gleo monster
from the original Legend of Zelda which
is a multi-headed dragon that famously
made a reappearance in tears of the
kingdom and this is further backed by
the fact that its appearance in the
non-canon AL Link to the Past manga
portrays trinex as a three-headed dragon
though it's never outright referred to
as trinex in the manga itself this means
it could share an evolutionary
connection to gleo which is pretty cool
to think about now there's one more boss
to talk about that resides with within
the dark world but he's a bit unique
from the rest of the monsters that we've
talked about so far so I saved him for
the last bit of this section the boss of
Thieves toown is a Darkness loving goon
whose name is blind blind the thief I'll
go into more of this in the eventual
dungeon lore video but thieves toown is
located underneath the village of
outcasts which is the Dark World variant
of kakaro Village in fact thieves toown
is also known as the gargoyle's domain
because it's located directly underneath
a gargoyle statue in the village of
outcasts which is the Dark World variant
of the weathercock in kakaro if you
enter this Old Stone House in kakaro a
man will tell you that it used to be The
Hideout of a gang of Thieves run by
blind the thief which is a very
interesting origin story for blind it
proves that he and all of his thieves
actually came from the light world and
most likely used to be hen however due
to his greed to steal anything of value
eventually of course he desired the most
valuable Relic in all the land the
Triforce itself huh a King of Thieves
wanting the Triforce for himself you
know I wonder why that sounds familiar
anyway blind either discovered somehow
or was otherwise supernaturally hinted
at that the Triforce was resting within
the Dark World formerly known as the
sacred realm so at some point he figured
out how to cross Into the Dark World and
did just that however as some astute
fans may know the dark world is a
magical realm one that is cursed into
transforming living creatures from the
light world into physical forms that
reflect their true nature which could be
anything from a monster to an animal to
a plant or just a random object like
this little ball dude here who claims he
was transformed into a ball because he
was just so indecisive and had no you
know hard edges even link himself
initially gets transformed into a bunny
rabbit which isn't explicitly explained
but implies that it's due to either his
true nature being timid or pure also um
here's a little bonus section that I
wasn't really planning on doing but I'm
going to do anyway uh if you're still
watching this prove it by letting me
know in the comments below what you
think you would transform into if you
entered the Dark World and if you are
still watching thank you you I love you
blind the thief on the other hand
straight up transforms into a demon one
that can shape shift in order to fool
his enemies however ever since he was a
human he apparently always hated the
light and would only emerge from his
Hideout at night sending his goons out
to rob people in the daytime this is a
weakness of his that is carried over to
his demon form and even though he
initially tries to fool link by turning
into the maiden that link is trying to
rescue from blind he's eventually
exposed underneath a patch of light and
is forced to reveal his true form he was
clear really a very evil-natured man not
only proven by his affinity for thievery
and his demonic transformation
implicative of his demonic true nature
but also because of his capacity for
deception in the non-canon bonus dungeon
called the Palace of the four sword
blind makes a reappearance and instead
decides to taunt link by transforming
into his uncle muttering the last words
link heard him say which is pretty
disturbing if you ask me with all the
Dark World bosses out of the way except
for the final boss of course let's turn
our attention to the light World bosses
of which there are three technically
four the boss says of the first dungeon
the Eastern Palace are a group of six
armest Knights now if that name sounds
familiar that's because armos enemies
have appeared in nearly every Zelda game
to date from the original title all the
way to Skyward Sword in each case they
always appear as statues that will
Spring to life in order to engage in
combat against something they consider
an enemy usually link it is to be
assumed that their mechanisms are
technical in nature instead of
Supernatural but that's speculative the
Arma kns of A Link to the Past are
simply larger versions of these standard
armos enemies it's very likely that
armases are high in in origin since they
typically appear within palaces or
temples constructed by hens such as the
Eastern Palace in A Link to the Past and
in this case specifically they were
likely placed here to stand as a trial
for anyone who would try to claim the
pendant of Courage that they guarded
they do reappear later on in the game
within ganon's Tower itself but you know
stealing a group of statue Knights is
probably a pretty easy task for the King
of Thieves the boss of the second life
light World dungeon the Desert Palace is
once again actually multiple bosses
called Lan molas this is another
reappearing enemy for the franchise
having made its debut appearance in the
original Legend of Zelda Lan molas are
monstrously large worm centipede insect
things that burrow underneath the ground
and resurface to attack their prey and
are covered in armor with their only
weak points being their heads for all
intents and purposes they appear to
Simply Be Wildlife that were placed here
again in order to safeguard the pendant
of power should there be a hero Brave
enough to attempt to claim it for
themselves as a reminder there are three
pendants in A Link to the Past and A
Link Between Worlds called the pendants
of virtue that are used to prove that an
individual is worthy of claiming the
master sword for themselves which is why
they're each guarded by powerful beings
which also implies that the Guardians
are placed there by Design the last
pendant the pendant of wisdom is guarded
by the third light World boss the mold
dorm in the tower of Hera the moldorm
shares an incredibly similar explanation
to the Lan mola in that it's also a
giant worm sent to Beed insect thing
that also appeared in the first game and
that also has only one vulnerable spot
although this time it's on its tail
instead of its head moldorm also make
many appearances across the franchise
and are usually faced as common enemies
instead of bosses making its appearance
in A Link to the Past unique both the
group of Lan molas and the moldorm make
reappearances in ganon's Tower at the
end of the game but that doesn't mean
they're not still a wild monster species
native to hyru which is what I think is
still most likely now there is
technically one more boss that link
faces in the World actually before he
faces any of the ones I just mentioned
way back at the start of the game right
before link rescues Princess Zelda from
her jail cell he has to face a
formidable ball and chain Trooper now
this is the only boss on this list
that's really just a hen Soldier one
that's located in hyru Castle and that's
equipped with hen armor and a hen weapon
in this case the ball in chain however
he fights against link because he's been
brainwashed by the mysterious wizard
known as agon in order to Aid the
Warlock in his Dark Quest to banish the
the sage descendants Princess Zelda
included there isn't much more to
explain about the guy other than the
fact that it's unfortunate he was
brainwashed and therefore died because
of it I mean who knows he might have
been kind of cool before going all crazy
with all of the dark and light World
bosses finally explained away it's time
to focus on the one who started it all
the King of Thieves himself Ganon
formerly known as Ganondorf dragmire
also known as the evil wizard Agony his
alter ego and I'm really excited to get
into it because this is one of the
coolest backstories to any villain I've
ever known but to explain all of that
we've got to First rewind to before the
events of the game took place according
to the lore derived from both a link to
the past and the Canon Zelda Timeline
Ganondorf was originally just a man who
coveted the power of the Triforce his
backstory about being a King of Thieves
that hailed from the land of the gudo is
more fleshed out in the prequel game
known as ocarine of time and the
parallel game in the adult timeline
known as The Wind Waker and if you'd
like a more in-depth explanation into
his appearances as Ganondorf in either
of those games feel free to check out
those videos after this one
however it is still important to know
that after the events of arrina of time
the timeline itself and therefore
Ganondorf himself split into three
separate continuities and in this case
we're dealing with ganondorf's story
after he used the Triforce of power to
transform into the two-legged Pig demon
known as Ganon and defeated Link at the
end of oine of time and spawned the
Fallen timeline as The Story Goes
following those events the Triforce
either in its entirety or simply the
pieces of power and wisdom apparently
returned to the sacred realm where it
had originally been placed which
prompted Ganon to re-enter the sacred
realm also known as the golden land in
order to obtain the full Relic it is
said that his followers went with him
into the golden land but were killed by
their leader Ganon in order to leave no
Challenger standing once the full
Triforce was securely within ganon's
grasp his evil power spread throughout
the entire golden land transforming it
from the peaceful sacred realm into the
dangerous Dark World as Ganon went a
little power crazy transforming
everything into his own kingdom of
darkness his power began to leak out
into the regular light World prompting
the king of hyru to elect seven wise men
also known as the sages to seal the
entrance to the Dark World up in an
attempt to lock Ganon and his evil away
however before they could successfully
seal the Dark Realm away Ganon sent his
new Army of monsters through the Gateway
and into hyu to lay Siege to the castle
leading to a war breaking out between
the Knights of hyru and the army of
Ganon who were enhanced magically by the
full power of the Triforce just as the
forces of Darkness were about to conquer
the Knights of Hyrule and enter the
castle the sages succeeded in the seal
cutting off the power of the Triforce
from ganon's army and leading to their
utter defeat this war was known as the
first imprisoning war with the second
occurring at an unknown point in time
against another Ganondorf entirely with
another set of sages entirely according
to tears of the Kingdom anyway as the
years went by hyru moved past the legend
of the Triforce in the dark world and
the imprisoning war but Ganon did not
eventually he concocted a new even
deadlier plan which began with a sailing
hyru once again with disasters there
began to be plages droughts earthquakes
and fires that broke out everywhere and
the king of hyu tried every magic known
to man in order to cease the misfortunes
but to no avail enter phase 2 of ganon's
plan his alter ego known as agon now
this is my own Theory but I personally
believe that agon was already a wizard
of the land of hyru that somehow
contacted or was contacted by Ganon from
the alternate realm and this contact led
to agon either willingly or unwillingly
being possessed by a spirit of Ganon the
reason I say this is because agon is
faced once again at the end of the game
within ganon's Tower and upon his second
defeat releases a ghostly image of Ganon
that then transforms into a bat and
returns to Ganon himself waiting within
the Pyramid of power leaving agon's
physical body crumbled lifelessly on the
floor in my opinion if Agony were to be
just a fabrication of ganon's magic his
body would combust like all the other
monsters in the game after they're
defeated but it doesn't which makes it
more likely that the body is actually
real and thinking about agon's existence
this way would expl explain how Ganon
was able to plague the land of Hyrule
even though his power had been
completely sealed away within the dark
world I mean if he had just been able to
waltz through the door as an alter ego
the whole time then what was the point
of the seal in the first place however
this is just my personal Theory and not
one that has been confirmed on any
official media anywhere meaning you can
choose to believe it or not at your
discretion back to the backstory though
agon approached the king in his
Majesty's desperation and offered to rid
the land of its ailments using his new
unknown magic the king accepted this
proposal and sure enough agon was able
to stop the disasters entirely this led
the very impressed King to promote agon
to the level of adviser to the king heir
to the sages and hero to the people of
Hyrule however after agon had risen to
effectively the second most powerful
political seat in the realm he began to
work behind the scenes to bring phase
three of his plan into fruition which
entailed influencing the people of
Hyrule through dark magic hence the ball
and chain Trooper after the pieces were
in place he killed the king of hyru on
his Throne leaving his Majesty's very
own lifeless bones to sit in the
powerless chair then he began hunting
down the descendants of the sages six
innocent maidens banishing them to the
Dark World one by one inside
indestructible Crystal prisons in order
to break the seal on the Dark World and
release Ganon back into the world and he
was 100%
sex and he was 100% successful in his
plan until he got to his last victim the
Princess Zelda herself Zelda who was
gifted with telepathic Powers due to her
goddess bloodline was able to send a
message magically to link and his uncle
requesting help and this is where the
events of the game begin Link awakes in
the middle of the night reaches Zelda
rescues her from agon's grasp retrieves
the master sword then returns to Zelda
to find that agon has already captured
her and confronts the wizard in Hyrule
castle where he discovers that he was
too late and agon has already banished
Zelda to the Dark World link then fights
against agon for the first time but
before he's able to defeat him agon
escapes into the Dark World bringing
link with him at this point agon takes a
very passive role until the end of the
game awaiting Link's arrival in ganon's
Tower when link arrives he's finally
able to defeat him revealing the spirit
of Ganon that was possessing agon's body
which transforms into a bat and returns
to Ganon within the Pyramid of power Lyn
spares no time at all in flying directly
to the pyramid and confronting Ganon
himself and after a brief exchange with
the Demon King regarding Link's fate
Ganon is finally soundly defeated by
being fatally shot with a light Arrow
after which link is able to retrieve the
Triforce and return burn the land to
light it's important to note that this
is the end of the first ganon's life and
all subsequent appearances in the Fallen
timeline are due to his followers
attempting to resurrect him but we'll
get to those appearances in their own
videos now won't we and with that we
have now completely explained every
single boss in the legendary Zelda game
A Link to the Past did you learn
something new did I miss anything let me
know in the comments below and thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed the
video or at least my efforts into making
it please consider leaving a like to get
it spread around on YouTube and
subscribe if you haven't already for
much more gaming lore to come huge
thanks as always to my Bandit crew who
make my day every day and are the reason
I can continue to make videos on the
channel that's all I've got for this one
so be sure to follow me on my socials
and I'll see you next time I've got a
few other videos planned for this month
so this isn't goodbye to 2023 just yet
anyway this is Bandit signing out
[Music]
peace